в Київ прийшла зима але ми маємо
пам'ятати що і на фронт зима прийшла і
ми маємо робити ще більше для того щоби
підтримати збройні сили України нічого
важливішого для нас зараз немає зараз у
нас є нова техніка нова в сенсі того що
ми ніколи її не поставляли і ми зробили
все щоб привести в порядок це п'ять татр
формула колісна 8 на8 повітряне
охолодження військова машина яку ми з
зібрали зробили то привезли і вони йдуть
в 10й армійський корпус сьогодні
відвантажується 11 вантажівок DAF
вантажівки DAF ідуть в десантникам і
артилеристам і 15 бригада артилерійської
розвідки і 95тка і 82 і
77 Що ж цінніше з цих вантажів бо всі
просять все це є
партія яку сьогодні просять і кажуть
дайте хоч одну шину дайте хоч дві немає
машини розуті а ми веземо
298 шин
уралівських і ми веземо 260 болотних шин
все це йдуть всі без виключення бригади
десантні часткова бригади сухопутних
військ артилерії артилерийської розвідки
два красеня фодина
які себе дуже добре зарекомендували тому
що вони евакуюють привозять боєприпаси
евакуюють пошкоджену техніку і роблять
це за півтори хвилини вони йдуть в 170
батальйон логістики командування
десантно-штурмових військ це є Як ви їх
називали скарб Ви жартували оце є скарб
і скарб який на сьогоднішній день все ще
постачають волонтери ми збираємо на
складах і від нтажуємо на фронт а це є
скоби для того щоби мали можливість
будувати фортифікаційні споруди
укріплення бліндажі Це нашого
виготовлення ми Таким чином реагуємо на
потреби проблема не тільки витратити
гроші проблема щоби довести розмитнити
перевірити і передати Оце є сім
авторемонтних майстерень те що дуже-дуже
просять тому що необхід швидко
відновлювати боєздатність пошкодженої
техніки На жаль пошкодженої техніки У
нас багато і сім авторемонтних
майстерень це найбільша партія яка
одноразово
відвантажувалася нашою командою Та це є
сім
банно-прачних комплексів і сьогодні
взимку Ми намагаємося зробити щоби в
кожному батальйоні вони були ніхто в
такому обсязі
одноразово не відвантажує таку кількість
продукції Сьогодні ми відвантажуємо
продукції більше як на 51 млн грн за раз
за один раз раніше я пам'ятаю з 14-го
року таку суму крупні благодійні фонди
збирали За півтора-два роки Сьогодні ми
це робимо За півтора тижня і ми на цьому
не збираємося зупинятися Це теж те що
дуже потрібно на фронті це теж створює
настрій тут зараз розташовано
1320 Київських тортів за ними також
вишукується черга Завтра вони будуть на
сході Завтра вони будуть в частинах і
завтра наші бійці які роблять для нас
все можливе які бережуть Україну які
рятують нашу землю які нищать ворога ми
робимо все щоби банію торта
майстернями фодинами шинами татрами
дафами лейдлендами яфами створити їм
настрій на
мльн працюємо підтримуємо збройні сили
Слава збройним силам і слава
Україні